[Music]
i do love the fact of playing fun video
games and just talking about conspiracy
theories that's actually one of my
favorite
he men aren't gonna kill himself i was
watching a long play of ninja turtles
but also i think our government's run by
reptiles
what do you push
you just hit him just hit him hit him
don't be a [ __ ] you hit him
no no frozen's frozen you're jj
high five
high five
thank you
guys guys you guys aren't high-fiving
enough
how do i know we are brothers
so if you reach a certain goal who's
take no man i'm not even going to say
that
this you know
you know it's funny like at the end i
know it's gonna end up being me at the
at the end of this they have like one of
those gi joe the more you know like i
think hey guys this is michelangelo and
i'm a serious party dude but i want to
talk about 911 being an inside job
wait what
what's up guys it's michelangelo i love
you know you all know i love to dance
you know who else loves to dance for
israelis at the base of the towers
[Laughter]
hey guys what's up michelangelo here
again you know i love pizza you know who
else loves pizza john podesta in the
comment ping pong pizza
you know what's not radical tunnels
where you sex traffic kids
[Laughter]
[Music]
that isn't that's not very cowabunga at
all guys
touching kids is not
touching kids is
touching kids is totally not pizza it's
not pizza at all
it's
hey guys you know we just
we're a bunch of talking reptiles but
would it be crazy to tell you that
reptiles run the government hey guys
mike hey guys michelangelo here again
turns out i'm in hiding
the government is after me
[Laughter]
just make sure you use hashtag save
mikey dot
turns out when you leak the entire
epstein flight log people get kind of
mad at you
they said mikey that's not radical
that's not radical at all
[ __ ] come on there you go got him
hey guys hi i'm michelangelo and i know
what you're thinking and the answer is
yes i am italian and here's a recipe for
a really great ravioli
[Laughter]
speaking of ravioli
did you know that the third that there
was a third tower
i can't believe i'm making money doing
conspiracy theories to play ninja
turtles
i mean it's a niche i've never heard of
it it's [ __ ] first one for me guys
oh that was the wang one okay that one
played
okay you all died let's go
i mean i could do this all show this is
[ __ ] hard
oh
hey guys michelangelo here yeah
shredder's a bad guy but you know who's
the worst dude george soros
alex jones here no it's actually casey
jones sorry about that [ __ ] that's
right casey jones's voice by alex jones
oh
you see the foot there
they represent the globalists
hey guys michelangelo here now you know
us we're always fighting the foot clan
but i'm here to talk to you about a
different kind of foot clan incels on
the internet
[Laughter]
they're turning the freaking battle
toads gay
hey michelangelo here we sure had a fun
time but i want to talk to you about
crisis actors
hey michelangelo here you spent your
hard earned money on a slice of pizza in
a long day what if i told you our
money's not backed by anything and it's
bound to collapse
here uh i was making a quality joke but
i don't want to cost the show
[Laughter]
hi i'm michelangelo and i'm charles
barkley we're going to talk about jews
in the media
[Laughter]
this is
hey what's up michelangelo here i just
want to tell you how they're putting
tracking chips in the coven vaccines
i'm michelangelo you know i love pizza
but you know what's not pizza 5g
[Laughter]
hey michelangelo here again you know
craig's really bad but you know who's
even worse hillary clinton
you might say to me michelangelo
you might say to me michelangelo 5g is
not that bad i feel fine well i've got
news for you i used to look like a
normal human male 1
seriously like these are tumors not
muscles seriously i act like i'm happy
all the time but i don't even have a
penis apparently
it's just shell
hi i'm michelangelo and i'm in radical
mode do you also want to be in radical
mode well i've got something called
crystal meth
hey michelangelo here did you know that
that our us government officials use
baby's baby blood to stay young
you may call us reptiles but the real
rap doesn't people deliver government
hey this is michelangelo just want to
tell you about pedophile vampires
hey michelangelo here that's right
michelangelo here imagine if you got
kicked out of 109 pizza parlors
you'd probably be the problem
oh i'm sorry yeah jewish people have
been kicked out of 109 countries
oh of the game you mean sorry i thought
you were okay
hi michelangelo here i walked by tupac
yesterday
tupac's alive and well hey michelangelo
here i'm going to be on owen benjamin's
podcast this weekend
hey michelangelo this is pretty gnarly
but you know it's not gnarly stan
stanley krubrick filming the moon
landing
hey guys michelangelo here speaking of
the foot plan did you know that the
pentagon lost 2 trillion on the budget
report just got couple days before the 9
11 attacks
and now you know
turtle power
michelangelo here did you know anything
about the dancing israelis during 9 11.
this is amazing it's [ __ ] so stupid
yeah you guys don't have any conspiracy
theories everything there's just weird
it was yeah it killed a bunch of native
kids in the 90s that's pretty much all
we got oh that pretty that's pretty
metal though that's about it that's
pretty bad guys i'm michelangelo and you
know fighting bad guys has me traveling
all around the world and i fly to all
these awesome places speaking of flying
i want to talk to you about the denver
international oh don't do it don't the
art's weird i wouldn't
i wouldn't
you know what else does it make sense
what michelangelo you know what else
does it make sense that the security
guard from the vegas shooting
only did ellen only only did ella
degeneres show that doesn't make sense
at all
hey guys michelangelo you're back on
that now hey guys you know it's not
cowabunga
the fact that they had the fact that
they had a bunch of cameras in the vegas
shooting but no one figured out how that
guy took up so much ammo up those
elevators by himself and took down a
bulletproof window
that's not cowabunga guys
hi i'm michelangelo and when i'm not
fighting bad guys sometimes i'm deleting
emails but you know what i'm not doing
deleting thousands at a time because
that's just us
hey michelangelo here hillary clinton
had a private server
hey michelangelo here did you know
hunter biden's laptop implicates him as
a potential pedophile
man michelangelo is [ __ ] based i
don't realize
zoomer michelangelo here
pizza is busting frfr no cap
teenage mutant zoomer turtles
[Laughter]
oh god gen z muse gen z bus and ninja
turtles
you say based after every fourth word
yeah my god
[ __ ] your face
heroes in a half shell
speaking of explosions 911 was a
controlled demolition
jet fuels don't melt steel beams
that's another gnarly fact michelangelo
jet fuel doesn't
jet fueled me jet fuel doesn't melt
steel beams but it can cook a pizza to
perfection
hey guys michelangelo here i've been
kicked out of the ninja turtles and i'll
be an infowars corn spawn from now on
be my best friend alex joe exactly alex
jones alex jones is my new splinter
alex here with uh my new uh best friend
uh michael angelo
hey alex what's up big fan
i only know him from my nephew casey
yeah this giant homosexual turtle has
spirit
he hasn't been gay yet
oh [ __ ]
alex jones is so based
we don't see that here
has somebody made a zoomer alex jones
yet
oh god
give him the hair and do the no cap
busted these globalists be busting for
real for real
speaking of power yes speaking of power
did you know two percent of the
population controls 100 of the banks
that's not radical
i did not like that that's not pizza
that's not pizza guys that's not pizza
at all
[Laughter]
hey captain zorax michelangelo here did
you know that the bones of your family
people are fighting for in the middle
east
[Laughter]
that's right when you die years later
you turn into something called fuel
michelangelo here climate change is a
lie
we must go underground to hide from the
globalists my children
[Laughter]
hey raphael it's me michelangelo yeah i
know i know you yeah sidebar bro i think
splinter started covid
i think i think it's because of splinter
you know i don't know if you know this
but pluto came from the wuhan section of
china
hey guys michelangelo here fighting
crimes expensive let me tell you about
super male vitality
sponsored by sponsored by super male
vitality
should imagine mine
if you had a bluetooth sponsorship
i just i just imagine i just imagine
michelangelo doing the podcast round and
having to be on rogan
uh so you're uh saying you're a teenage
ninja turtle yeah yeah but uh i didn't
come here to talk about jimmy pull up uh
pull the bullet up i remember they made
a movie about you guys in the 90s uh
jamie pull that up you know pedophiles
are stealing our kids joe i feel we
should talk about that more
michelangelo
michelangelo is playing
i'm michelangelo joe dubs 35 super
chatted five dollars hi michelangelo
here did you know hot pizza sauce
doesn't melt steel beans no i did not
know that
thank you mikey
cowabunga
[Music]
matty from dewoods 2 superchatted 5.66
hey guys michelangelo here did you know
there are guyonic who takes pictures in
the desert and convinced one hundreds of
thousands of people he's on mars yeah i
believe that because we live in a hell
world i already told you
uh oh
uh oh
oh oh this guy's getting up michael and
get in trouble mr c super shattered 4.99
mike angelo here
today i want to talk to you about fbi
crime statistics
no today nope i wouldn't those are not
very cowabunga
hold on ralph ralph stand next to me rob
all right route hey anybody there you go
hey guys the jews control them the jews
control the media high five i see you're
trying to get okay
hey guys the juice control the media
yeah no michelangelo would say it yeah
as the hands collapse yeah too late yeah
yeah exactly he's that he's a dick and
then everyone's like whoa wait what
like
come on man
oh [ __ ]
yeah the ninja turtles are not friends
outside of uh
work by the way all it is is like them
having an intervention michelangelo
walks into guys listen man
we have to stop focusing on the jew
thing and mike's like dude what's this
all a bit for
[Laughter]
then why are we even here
yeah he's really angry angel's really
anti-semitic for no reason
you know heather might have been right
yes that's that's what michelangelo
everyone's like cowabunga radical hitler
was right mike come on man
holy [ __ ] by the way by the way [ __ ]
the shredder and crank immediately stop
fighting and look at each other like hey
man look
listen dude
i hear you no no no no no
they stop
they stop and look at each other and
then they turn and they just look at the
other turtles and go
yeah you guys have fun with that yeah
and then you hear him walking away then
you hear him walking away and traders
like i ain't trying to be cancelled
[Laughter]
as they're leaving leonardo's going no
no no no no no no no god damn it yeah
exactly because i have a hundred
thousand followers da real shredder 69.
starting to pick up yeah look
look i'm big in the lgbt community i do
drag
[Laughter]
which would be really funny like
michelangelo's so anti-semitic that
shredder and crank just leave they give
up they just leave they just go no
yeah that's gonna be different
hey man look i know we're evil and [ __ ]
now that's what i call a jewish agenda
mike
mike
we're going to cancel us
hi i'm michelangelo you ever notice how
the guy from smash mouth and guy fieri
are never in the same room at the same
time
there it is michelangelo here can i tell
you something about
sandy hook oh don't do it
all right we need to cancel this guy yes
hi i'm michelangelo and i'm here to
apologize for my comments about sandy
hook
they were unfounded and based on on
rumor
hey guys michelangelo here i was fine
when it was a bunch of turtles but we're
letting the zionist journalists join our
group and i'm not cowabunga with that
hey i'm irish
now
yeah april o'neil's like i'm from
ireland
like it's like
i'm full-blooded irish yeah okay
oh neil steen
april o'neil steen i don't want to hear
it
hey mikey
all right then eat this pizza with bacon
on it all right we're gonna check the
suggestion box remember turtles this is
anonymous
listen mike i know this was you you keep
saying that you want to be called a
teenage mutant palestinian turtles and
we're not doing it
we were mike come on man
cowabunga
[Music]
oh no no i just read it
lord pepsi tipped 3.33
donatello says we're in a dome a battle
dome no
flat earth
[Music]
jack cat tipped three dollars hey guys
michelangelo here again
not really a conspiracy but remember
when vice president dick cheney shot his
friend in the face we don't talk about
that enough getting shot in the face is
definitely not pizza
[Music]
okay
i'm sorry not pizza is the best this is
so stupid
guys that's not pizza
the ghost off drag works tipped three
dollars hey kids michelangelo here today
i want to talk about the thousands of
food processing plants that have
exploded across the country the cia is
actively causing a food shortage that
will lead to civil unrest and a hostile
that's not pizza
oh we have another we have a couple more
michelangelo
[Music]
bit for shrines super shattered five
dollars cowabunga dudes michelangelo
here six million seems a little high
don't you think
oh no
[Laughter]
just a little
these guys are [ __ ] [ __ ] by the
way thanks a lot guys this is amazing
our listeners
super chatted three dollars april o'neil
here do you know jews do the news sexy
bro
april o'neil on assignment in israel
[Music]
joe dubs 35 super chatted five dollars
hey michelangelo here you know i heard
that ray epps is fed he should have told
people to go into a pizzeria instead the
capital
oh no
april keeps hitting the barrels because
she thinks jews are hiding in them
mikey you gotta stop believing alex
jones was right stickers on the techno
drone
i think michelangelo would be for or
against the ping-pong pizza
well he's against it because he likes
pizza but hates pedophiles hey guys
michelangelo here just here to remind
you birds aren't real
drones are meant by the government to
watch every move you do hey michael you
guys michelangelo here you ever seen the
baby pigeon i haven't you just took my
[ __ ] line i hate you
no but for real though i still have it
and i actively been looking for one for
a decade because they're actually
cameras
yeah they look
they actually look like real birds
[ __ ] felt they're just murdering
pigeons
michelangelo was right when he said
ritualistically molesting kids in the
pizza place basement is not pizza it's
not pizza no it's not
why are pizza making money doing this we
shouldn't third culture super shattered
three dollars
michelangelo here did you know you
didn't take
guns for cocaine in south america
did you know the 80s the cia traded guns
for coke and something
don't talk about the donations god damn
it camera chris super shattered 5.47
michelangelo here was the guy with the
funny moustache truly wrong
funny notes okay hold on and let me send
a super chat with his name in it hitler
hi
what if your name is jerry hitler danny
saint super chatted 4.99
michelangelo here i trust my pizza
delivery man more than the media which
consists of joe scarborough who had a
dead intern in his office
[Music]
oh here we go leo's apologizing for
mikey
[Music]
pat is cool tipped 3.33
leo here because of recent comments made
by our brother mickey he'll be on
assignment for the foreseeable future
he'll be replaced by that girl turtle on
one episode of power rangers
we're gonna have a girl turtle no
oh so wait leo's gonna be the
sjw yeah
oh no
oh oh look who it is
well well well if it isn't harvey
weinstein
finally guys all this is paying off
let's kill that big brain jew
they spelled weinstein
you're right well his name was harvey
krang weinstein
craig crankstein craig carrick
hey guys michelangelo here do you know
krang was the epstein flight logs
yeah what up [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's what all the barrels this
is minutes before she flips him open
flips him over and just penetrates his
ass
jeremiah
super chatted 4.99
donatello here know what's cowabunga and
pizza referring to your friends in their
proper pronouns oh no
[Music]
third culture super shattered
3.35 cents michelangelo here remember
kids epstein didn't kill himself
[Laughter]
oh boy the next one's wrong michelangelo
is getting crazy
the ghost of drag works tipped three
dollars hey kids michelangelo here let's
talk about the gay community did you
know that the cia used drag queens as a
means to turn you gay in order to assist
the globalists in depopulating the
planet say no to the rainbow and
remember kids pedos get the rope
oh [ __ ] michelangelo
michelangelo has been going a fourth
michael night supposed to go to 4chan
he's [ __ ] getting deep into it
here have some pizza and a pamphlet oh
mike come on man
michelangelo just has a his shell is
just full of inf informational leaflets
a globalist in you
hold on let's see
and there's still 10 minutes to watch
someone get shot on body camera
[Music]
5.66
donatello here you have to stop playing
krang just came out as non-binary and
this game has become a hate crime
patty's cool tipped
3.33 cents leo here reminding you to
take your booster mutagen remember be
safe be pizza
hey i got kc
be safe be pizza be pizza
these are all great guys
[Music]
zelo's node tipped 4.20
heroes with a hard r turtle power no no
no
no no
no
no
no
no
atomic shaman sweat lodge tipped five
dollars michelangelo here the techno
drone didn't hit building seven on the
11th of september
okay cowabunga
[Laughter]
george floyd was high on fentanyl hi
michelangelo here 4.99
hey michelangelo here just wanting to
let everyone know that i don't currently
have any plans of doing myself in the
back of my head oh he's worried that
he's going to make michelangelo kill
himself
michelangelo here
[Laughter]
heroes in a half shell white power
they're green silly
yeah but casey jones is their leader
look at him he looks like he would be at
a [ __ ] he looks like a patriot front
guy
oh it's like natives
native casey jones
you know they should casey jones should
be in charlottesville with a tiki torch
that would be hilarious